let's talk about something completely uh
irreverent irrelevant but uh you know
let's lighten the mood a little bit
so this is a big story former lizzo
dancers were weight shamed and pressured
while at strip club lawsuit says I like
how it says pressured while at strip
club uh not for the the kids I will say
but uh we'll we'll keep the uh overt
language to a minimum and uh my
understanding is that they were actually
physically abused
at these clubs they were they were
pressured into doing things and I I
don't know if we can say that on air
here but uh bananas were put places
bananas aren't supposed to go and then
they were told to eat them from the
places oh no don't blame me I'm just the
messenger here uh okay but here's I do
blame you as the pop culture yeah here's
here's the important part of the story
is why we're talking about it because
lizzo was weight shaming yes
lizzo is morbidly obese there can only
be one
okay this is my question is she saying
like you're too heavy or is she saying
you're not heavy enough oh that's a
great question yeah
like
if you really want to be in my tour
you'll eat all of the donuts like no one
has said it explicitly I don't
understand I spent about 20 minutes
talking about the day so I'm about over
this whole discussion I'll be completely
fair but it's uh I mean that's not the
worst there's really funny like mixed
messages where she's got like a lady who
works on the tour with her who's like
very religious but also like simulating
sex acts in front of people it's the
weirdest it almost feels fake the how
how over the top the story is but it's
it's gonna cost her I'll be honest I
don't really care about the inner
politics of lizzo but the issue I see is
the biggest cultural the culturally we
have this body positivity thing they say
lizzo is beautiful but then inside this
you know this company or whatever
they're telling these these people
they're too fat
so it's it's something like what is this
how does this how do these things
coexist yeah I also think this like the
point that they're saying like they're
at a strip club going to strip clubs is
like all of the uh women I know who
propose to be sex positive feminists are
like going to the strip club is
empowering and it's good and you should
go so it's this Clash of cultures where
it's like if you don't go then you are
not sex positive enough that's literally
and also when you go you're forced to do
things you're uncomfortable with and
maybe lizzo fat change your or perhaps
she's skinny shames you it's unclear
this is one of those things I don't
think they're talking about like well
the dancers yeah but were they
overweight enough I don't know you need
to put on a hundred pounds I'm just
saying she doesn't dance it's like the
stories of like Brides who get their
bridesmaids ugly bridesmaids dresses so
that she they look better by comparison
I just want to know what direction this
was happening his name is Melissa yes
that changes everything she's um these
are the people that push a very very
toxically positive message meaning like
that that you have to feign positivity
at all times which is not how the real
world works and as you learn invariably
like I said earlier anybody who puts be
kind in a profile is the meanest person
you've ever met in your entire life it's
the same in these industries the harder
The Virtue signal the worse they are as
a boss as an employer as a general human
being and if you read more of the story
later said I'm going to spare everyone
the deals it's no no no I I got a
question about this I'm not going to
read it and I'm Gonna Keep the language
as as vague as I can but NBC news says
okay no don't pull this up stick it out
all right all right NBC news says cast
members took turns catching objects
launched from certain areas of the body
yes how do you launched those things ask
the people at this at this strip club
just so fun company activity the best
part about it is there's like an
interview with her from like two years
before this happened where she talks
about how she always wanted to go to
this one strip club and that this was
because this is the red light district
in Amsterdam right so she's like
basically I love bananas I want to go
there to this strip club and now it's
coming back to bite her because she's
nuts
so why I'm sorry you're all men I don't
know
if you understand something I don't know
but this no this is also one of those
this is one of those things where like
look they were basically shamed into
doing this they're like well if you
don't come with you like you don't have
to but we'll judge you if you would be
like Tim saying like hey Brett you want
to go skating on Saturday I mean you
don't have to come but you know you
might not have a job on Monday if you
don't come with me that's literally what
it is or for the rest of the tour we'll
just treat you like you're exactly well
they said like she would do other
concerts that were not part of the tour
and the only the people who like hung
out with her outside at these events
were the ones who got those jobs so it's
basically just like do you remember when
oh no okay so recently Robert Downey Jr
had a thing where he talked about how
after making Oppenheimer said women
should run the world in in Oppenheimer
yeah they said women she's like what
this movie taught me is that women
should run the world because they have a
better way of handling problems this is
the exact proof to the opposite of that
that I don't know if it would be better
but or if it would be worse but it's
certainly not going to be any better
don't like being a bad boss is not
gendered doesn't like every
military-industrial complex Corporation
have like a female CEO or something not
all right now but yeah like a couple
years ago yeah like women should run run
the world and it's like there's a bunch
of women that are blowing up kids Boeing
is like yeah let's do that most men and
women are equally bad and good at
resolving problems but I do not think
women should exclusively around the
world it's like when people say like
there should be an all women's Supreme
Court like what are you talking about
that's a terrible idea Barbie movies
look no no the men and women are
different right men are object oriented
women are subject oriented so what
happens is when you've got like a
Hillary Clinton and like a Barack Obama
Obama sees a map and on the map he sees
a military base and he says I think we
should uh bought that military base and
then like oh let's get let's confer with
Hillary what she thinks and Hillary says
we should blow up those people yeah so
you see what I'm saying like Obama is
targeting some object of some Merit and
Hillary is like I hate them blow them up
so you say women are evils
more people at least she's being honest
about what's going to happen the uh but
the what it is it really is it shows it
shines a light on the toxic positivity
that this is what Hollywood and all
these industries push is like it's an
unrealistic expectation of how human
beings interact and invariably just like
men behind the scenes uh a bad you know
a bad tour manager a bad boss a bad
celebrity is not is not restricted to
one gender or one type of person but
very often it is true that the people
who feign the most kind of heart who
pretend to be the most good of heart or
good of virtue end up being the worst
type of people and I don't think that
has anything to do with a weight to
sexuality or a gender yeah you did bring
up a good point before we started this
was the essentially a inverse of the
casting couch and in multiple ways I
think but it is it is funny how that
literally is the casting couch situation
but in a different setting and so in
this setting maybe the illusion is
supposed to be somewhat okay I actually
don't even know it should be necessarily
legal but she should be shamed like
she's been I just wanted amazing I want
to give a shout out to the Babylon B for
like the best response to this with an
article they titled three dancers Sue
lizzo alleging she ate them and their
entire family
Joey B tune Joey B toon said good luck
to convincing that judge that the that
lizzo shared food
um yeah it's just it is it is just a
microcosm of just how awesome it's okay
to make fun of her though because she's
apparently some kind of rapist so you
know she's you know just a very bad
person the the rest of the stories the
stuff with the the assist the manager
who is also making everyone
uncomfortable and the threats to
people's job keeping people working for
like 12 hours at a time after a concert
and saying you're gonna lose your job if
you don't do that a lady who worked for
her
urinated on herself because she was
afraid to go backstage and go to the
bathroom because she felt she'd lose her
job that's the type of thing you'd hear
of a guy that a guy would be the one
who's such a hard boss that I felt like
I couldn't leave otherwise I would end
up having to female bosses are just as
whack as mailboxes I don't know what to
tell you well you and I know that the
average possible person these days this
is almost worse because it's like
emotional manipulation but my favorite
is uh the data showing that men and
women equally don't hire women at the
same rates so these women are like women
should be in charge and then things
would change and it's like the women who
are in charge like I'd rather have a guy
do women enforcement patriarchy there
was also there was also talk that there
was racialized elements to this like
that the the black dancers were treated
different than the dancers of color uh
they're no white dancers but dancers of
color no white dancers not racist though
no but but the point is that they're
saying that certain ones were treated
differently and it's all it all kind of
falls together it's like it's Hollywood
they deserve each other let them let
them fight wow you don't say it at big
girl touring yes I'm just yes you know
the body positivity thing is what I
first noticed from this story I mean the
story is whole like totally messed up
like nine articles it was like literally
split between like nine articles because
of all the stuff that came out about
this today I just think
how does lizzo get famous like do people
really like her music yes yeah yes she
had some like cool songs that I was
really she had one I think she has
insulin resistance I don't know anything
about her because that's the new single
I know that she released
um
trying to be funny I was being serious I
think I think she because she's on stage
and she's working like dancing so that's
the point she's talking about like the
other dancers can't keep up with her
because she's like actually in better
shape than them right and the reason she
doesn't lose weight is because she has
insulin resistance probably from like a
very poor American you know high sugar
diet anything I wish her the best
comes out with I have insulin resistance
it reminds me of like Kevin Costner
being like yes maybe stuff happened but
I'm choosing to live as a gay man and no
that was Kevin Spacey yeah I can't
remember any actor sure I was accused of
that but and if I did it's a drunken
Mistake by the way he got some news
about me he didn't get convicted in the
UK they let him off no but I mean the
the thing is like lizzo had some like um
I don't remember which one the one about
like being broken up with she wrote some
song and it was like not a hit and she
was like I'm gonna if if this isn't a
hit then I I don't know like she really
does understand pop music in a way it's
just that everything about her since
she's gotten famous has become like
about the body positivity movement about
accepting the way I am about actually
praise me the way I am and I think
that's the problem like it's not like I
don't know like Adele used to be really
heavy and she sang Some Fun music and
she was a pop star and it was a good
time
she went all right I'm gonna write I'm
gonna write this song What kind of song
should it be should it be like a
acoustic folk or should cause influence
called insulin resistance yes yes
acoustic folk like heartfelt and like
definitely definitely heartfelt that's
for sure
you know or maybe maybe punk rock
yeah that sounds like insulin resistance
doesn't feel like it could be like I
don't know I'm thinking dance disco yeah
I've been listening to some disco
recently because we were uh we were
listening to Boney M oh no because Boney
M is so good sweet maybe we should write
a disco song yeah
like I wonder how much it costs to get
lizzo like it's like a feature on this I
don't think she's gonna be wanna be on
myself sure sure we could try I don't
think lizard's gonna want to be on a
song titled lizzo has insulin resistance
what could just be called insulin
resistance this is
called resistance so and it's and it's
not meant to be mean I'm gonna make it
very clear I am genuinely concerned
about the bad dieting habits of
Americans awareness and I also it's it's
a point to be critical of someone who
would would weight shame her own staff
while she herself is is currently
suffering from a a weight issue she's
also counting on you not being mean to
her because of because of herself I
still think she's she's shaming her her
dancer saying they're too skinny I mean
I think it's the other way right I mean
there's different types of fact she's
clearly like o-line healthy type fat you
know what I mean like you can move you
know what I mean but that's the thing
that's why I said insulin resistance I
wasn't it was making a joke like people
I was the one being you see these videos
where it's like people who are very big
are like moving really well linebackers
yeah yeah and there's videos of
skateboarders for instance you'll see on
Instagram where they're huge but they'll
be skating really well and I'm just like
this is somebody who's got I don't know
if it's insulin resistance but some kind
of like I don't know thyroid problem or
glandular issue that their body isn't
burning the fat but they clearly are
building muscle and ability I see lizzo
and I'm like this is this is something
about the garbage plastic we eat in our
food every day the brominated flowers
the phthalates the pcbs all of that
stuff because the story I hear over and
over again I swear I ask everybody this
they say oh I was from this country and
when I came to America I ate the exact
same thing but I gained 30 pounds yeah
and people say I I you know when I went
back to visit my family for a few weeks
I lost 10 pounds it was crazy like
something is wrong with our food thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at p.m and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time